SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpeCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional material from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, we talked about
this a little bit last time.
We were talking about the
detection of vectors in white
Gaussian noise.
When we talk about vectors we'll
often refer to white
Gaussian noise as noise where
each component of the vector
is independent of each
other when they're
all the same variance.
Usually we take the variance
to be n0 over 2,
capital N0 over 2.
And we'll say more about that as
we go on, but that's just--
I guess one thing I ought
to say about it now--
people keep wondering why we
call this N0 over 2 instead of
something else.
As I said before, there's
really no reason
for it except custom.
The one important thing that
you can always remember and
which is always true is that any
time you're talking about
a sequence of real noise
variables they all have
variants N0 over 2, and the same
coordinate system that
you're using to measure
the signals.
OK, the only thing that ever
appears in any of these
formulas is a ratio of signal
power or signal energy to
noise signal power.
And if we're up it passband,
we're dealing with the power,
which is two times larger
than that at baseband.
And because of that-- and
this is what really gets
confusing-- is that when you
talk about N0 over 2 at
passband, you are talking about
something which is twice
as big as the N0 over 2, the
same N0 over 2 you were
talking about at baseband.
And the reason is since the
signal is twice as big there,
the noise is also said
to be twice as big.
I can't do anything
about that.
It's just the way that everybody
does things.
The other thing that everybody
does-- since everyone gets
confused about that--
is after they get all done
dealing with anything in a
paper they're writing or
something, they always look at
the signal to noise ratio that
they have and they remove all
the factors of two that they
know shouldn't be there.
So that you shouldn't trust
anything in the literature too
much as far as factors
of two are concerned.
And I try to be careful in the
notes about that, but you
shouldn't trust the notes too
far along those lines, either.
So well eventually I'll get the
notes straightened out on
all of that but I think they're
pretty close now.
But anyway, we were looking at
this question of how do you
detect antipodal vectors in
white Gaussian noise?
And the picture that we
can draw is this.
Namely we have two signals.
One is the vector, a, one
is the vector, minus a.
It's in some finite dimensional
system, but we're
viewing it as far as drawing
a picture as a
two dimensional system.
So a has some arbitrary
component
in the first direction.
Some arbitrary component in
the second direction.
Minus a is, of course,
the reverse of that.
This point right in here is
the zero point, which is
halfway in between them.
And the output that we observe
is either plus or minus a,
plus this independent zero mean
noise, Z, which has the
kind of circular symmetry
indicated here with these
little circles.
Each of the Z sub i have the
same variance, they're
independent of each other.
And when you write down the
likelihood of the probability
density of this output, given
that the hypothesis was zero.
Namely that plus a was the
signal which was chosen.
OK, remember in all of these
things there's this process
now going on that we usually
don't talk about anymore.
But there's an input coming into
the communication channel
which we're now calling
capital H. It's the
hypothesis-- which is the thing
you're trying to detect
when you're all done--
that input which is one up to
capital N, or sometimes zero
up to capital N minus 1.
Is then mapped into a signal
from a single set of capital N
different signals.
So they're impossible signals
in this signal alphabet.
You map the hypothesis
into one of those.
From those, you generally
form a waveform.
This waveform might be
modulated up to high
frequency, back to low
frequency again.
Detected or whatever.
You got some vector,
v, at that point.
Which is a sequence of samples
that you're going to be taking
as far as most cases
are concerned.
We'll talk more about
that later today.
But anyway, v is a vector which
is plus or minus a at
this point, plus this
Gaussian noise.
We can write down the
probability density of that
vector, v, which is if
hypothesis zero occurs.
Namely if a zero enters the
communication channel, plus a
is the signal which is chosen.
Then what happens is that the
output is a plus Z. Which
means that the probability
density of the
noise is v minus a.
So we have this probability
density here.
When we look at the log
likelihood ratio, we're taking
the logarithm of this
probability density divided by
the probability density of the
alternative hypothesis.
Namely v given one.
Which is the same as this
formula except there's the
plus a there instead
of a minus a.
So you get this thing here.
Now, why I wanted to talk about
this today is we're
going to talk about the
complex case also and
something very, very peculiar
and funny happens there.
OK so the log likelihood ratio
is the scaled difference of
the energy of the distance
between v and a.
Which is this term here.
This is just a squared distance
between the vector,
v, and the vector, a.
It's v minus a is that distance
there, squared.
And the other term here is the
term that comes from the
probability density
of v given one.
Which turns out to be that
distance there squared.
So you have the difference
between these two things.
This is just the inner product
of v minus a with v minus a.
And if you multiply that all out
it's the inner product v
with itself, plus the inner
product of a with itself,
minus the inner product of v and
a, minus the inner product
of a with v.
The only things that don't
cancel out between these two
things is the inner product of v
with a, the inner product of
a with v, the inner product of v
a with v. So those things last
because there's a minus sign
here and a plus sign here.
There's a minus sign here
and a plus sign here.
So the plus and minus signs
cancel out, so you just get
four of these terms here, which
is four times the inner
product over n0.
What happens to that
geometrically?
What is the inner product
of v and a?
Well it's the projection
of v on the vector a.
Which happens to be the line
between minus a and plus a.
Mainly the fact that it's the
line between minus a and plus
a is the thing which is valuable
whether you're
dealing with antipodal
communication or any other
kind of communication.
You're always looking at this
line between two points.
So what this thing says is you
form the inner product, which
says drop a perpendicular from
Z down to here, and in terms
of where that perpendicular
lands here,
you make your decision.
Namely you compare that
with the threshold.
OK?
So we have two different
ways of doing this.
One of them is compare this
distance with this distance.
Or actually here you compare the
square distance here with
the square distance there.
Which says, if you're using
maximum likelihood then the
threshold that you're dealing
with here is zero and you
simply make your decision on
whether the log likelihood
ratio is positive or minus.
Which means in terms of the
projection theorem here, what
you're doing is taking a
perpendicular bisector of the
line between minus a and plus
a, and putting a plane there
and that's the plane that
separates what goes into one
and what goes into zero.
This goes into zero.
This goes into one.
OK, so is it clear to all of you
that this is really saying
the same thing as this?
This inner product just
comes from here.
You can either look at this as
minimum distance decoding.
You just find the
point which is
closest to what you receive.
You find the hypothesized
signal, which is closest to
the actual observation
that you make.
You make your decision
in terms of that.
Or you do this projection
and make your
decision in terms of that.
And if you use a triangle thing
which says that this
squared distance plus this
squared distance is equal to
that squared distance.
We all remember that from third
grade or something.
I don't know when.
But that simply says the same
thing that this says.
This just says it
more generally.
In terms of an arbitrary finite
conventional vector,
rather than just the case of
where you're looking at two
dimensions.
OK that's--
we will probably come back to
look at that in a little bit,
but now I want to look at
complex antipodal vectors in
white Gaussian noise.
So the set up there is that
the input is some vector.
I usually use u's to mean
complex numbers.
So the vector there is u1 up to
u sub j where u sub j is a
complex number.
So we're dealing with complex
vectors at this point.
So we have two points, minus
a -- minus u and plus u.
Where instead of being
a real vector
they're complex vectors.
And if you can't visualize
things geometrically, in terms
of complex vectors,
join the crew.
I can't either.
The only thing I can never do
is talk about real vectors,
try to get some idea of what's
going on from that, and use
mathematics for the
complex vectors.
Because the reason we use
complex vectors is that,
analytically they're just as
simple as real vectors.
The reason we use real vectors
is because we can draw
pictures of them.
I defy anybody to draw a picture
in four dimensions.
Some books will do it, but
I can't understand them.
And anyway.
OK, so under hypothesis zero
what gets sent as u?
And under hypothesis one, what
gets sent as minus u?
So we're still talking about
binary communication and if
you're talking about antipodal
vectors, you can't do much
other than talk about binary
communication.
Because if you're sending a, the
only vector antipodal to a
is minus a.
And then you're stuck
and you're done.
So we're still talking
about binary vectors.
Remember the reason why
we're doing this--
because one of the things we
did last time, one of the
things that's in the notes and
stressed again and again is
that once you understand the
antipodal case, you can
translate those two points
anywhere you want to and the
maximum likelihood decision and
the MAP decision are still
the same thing.
You take those two points and
you just translate them in
space until the mean between
them sits on the zero point.
And then you're back to the
antipodal case again.
OK, so the reason why we're
doing this is really so we can
look at the more general case.
But we don't have to have
that mean sitting
around all the time.
OK, Z then is going to be a
vector of j complex IID
Gaussian random variables.
IID real and imaginary parts.
Namely the real part of each
Gaussian, complex Gaussian
random variable has variance
n0 over 2 and the imaginary
part also has variance
n0 over 2.
These complex vectors, if you
look at the probability
density for them and you draw it
in two dimensions, one for
the real part one for the
imaginary part, you get this
circular symmetry that we've
always associated.
Those are supposed to be circles
and not ellipses.
And those are sometimes
called proper complex
Gaussian random variables.
Because almost everywhere where
you see complex Gaussian
random variables, the real
and imaginary parts are
independent of each other and
both have the same variance.
Again, when you look at formulas
in papers, formulas
everywhere else, they are almost
always assuming this
kind of circular symmetry.
Or what's often called proper
complex random variables.
Sort of accepting the fact that
anything else is very,
very improper.
It's improper because formulas
don't work in that case.
OK, so we have a vector of these
complex IID Gaussian
random variables.
Under H equals zero, the
observation, v, is given by v
equals u plus Z. And under
hypothesis one, the
observation is given by minus
u plus Z. So I have exactly
the same cases as
we had before.
OK in other words almost all
formulas stay the same when
you go from real to complex.
But I don't trust the complex
case and you shouldn't either
until you at least go
through it once.
So what I'm going to do now is
translate this complex case to
the real case.
In other words, for each complex
variable I'm going to
make two real variables.
One the real part and one
the imaginary part.
We know that the real part and
the imaginary part are
independent of each other.
And if these Gaussian random
variables are independent of
each other, then the real and
imaginary parts of each of
them are independent of the real
and imaginary parts of
each of the other side.
OK?
So we can go from j Gaussian
random variables, independant
Gaussian random variables,
which are complex.
To 2j Gaussian random variables,
which at this point
are going to be real.
OK so it's just a translation
from j complex variables to 2j
real variables.
Again we can't draw pictures of
things in this j dimension,
we can start to draw pictures
in 2j dimensions.
If you talk about a probability
density for a
complex random variable, what
are you talking about?
How do you write the probability
density for just a
plane Gaussian complex
random variable?
What is it?
Anybody know what it is?
Is it one dimensional or
is it two dimensional?
What does probability
density mean?
It means probability
per unit area.
What does area mean when
you're talking
about complex numbers?
Well you sort of mean what
you've drawn there, yes.
And you're looking at areas in
this complex plane here.
So that in fact when you write
the probability density for a
complex random variable, what
you have already done whether
you want to do it or not is
you've converted the problem
to real and imaginary part.
That's what the probability
densities are.
Excuse me for a belaboring this
but, if I don't belabor
it I mean there's a catch
here that comes
along in a little bit.
And you won't understand to
catch if you don't understand
why these things are almost the
same as real variables up
until the catch comes.
OK, so we're going to
deal with these 2j
dimensional real vectors.
The components will be real part
of u j, imaginary part of
u j for what goes into
the channel.
And we'll let capital Y capital
Z prime be the two j
dimensional real versions
of V and Z.
OK so that we'll call Y the real
part, an imaginary part
of Z. And you notice that what's
going on here is the
same thing that's going on
when you modulate QAM.
You take a complex signal, you
multiply it by either the 2pi
j carrier frequency times t, and
then we started to look at
orthonormal expansions, you
remember that what we looked
at-- as far as the real signals
that were actually
being transmitted on the
channel-- was the real part of
that u of t times z to the
blah, blah, blah, and the
imaginary part of u of t
times blah, blah, blah.
So you've got two orthonormal
functions in place of one
complex orthonormal function.
And that's the same thing
that's going on here.
It's just not with immodulation
put in, it's just
dealing with the real parts and
imaginary parts directly.
OK, so if we do that we get
a bunch of equations.
They're sort of familiar
looking
equations by now I hope.
This is just the probability
density of this real 2j
dimensional random variable.
Which is all this junk that
we're used to seeing.
We can collapse that into
e to the minus the norm
squared of y minus a.
This is the norm squared
in this 2j
dimensional real space.
It's not the norm squared
in this complex space.
What gets confusing is
that those two norms
are exactly the same.
As we'll see in just
a few minutes.
But anyway, what we're dealing
with now is this
norm in real space.
OK, note that's y--
oh let me translate
this one for you.
If we think of this v that we
received j complex random
variables as being: real part
of v1, imaginary part of v1;
real part of v2, imaginary part
of v2; and so forth, then
y2j minus 1 minus
a2j minus one.
I can't ever get these
formulas right.
That should be a2j minus 1.
There.
This squared, plus
this squared--
OK, in other words the real part
squared of the difference
plus the imaginary part squared
of the difference-- is
really just the same is
vj minus uj squared.
OK, in other words you take the
complex number v sub j,
you subtract off the real
number u sub j.
And the way to do that, you
visualize this one complex
variable in the complex plane,
and what you're doing is
you're taking the square of the
real part of the distance,
you're adding it to
the square of the
imaginary part of the distance.
OK, all of this is stuff you
learned in high school.
Just viewed in a slightly
different way.
OK, now when you take the
probability density with
respect to these complex
vectors--
which is what I want
to get at--
probability density of these
complex variables really means
the same thing as that with
the real variables.
But then you wind up
with the magnitude
of vj minus uj squared.
And this term is really exactly
the same as these two
terms there.
So when you take this
probability density, you wind
up with these terms the same and
with these terms the same.
OK, in other words the complex
norm squared is the same as
the real norm squared, when you
go from complex to real
and imaginary parts of,
well-- as I said, this
is the same as that.
OK so when we look at the log
likelihood ratio, then, let's
do the log likelihood ratio in
terms of the real parts first.
We get the difference between
this norm squared of y minus
a, and the norm squared
of y plus a.
This is the part that comes from
the hypothesis zero, this
is the part that comes from
the hypothesis one.
OK, so we get these
two terms here.
When we take the inner products
here, we get the same
thing that we got before.
Four times the inner
product of yna.
Now, the whole reason for going
through all of this is
this next formula.
When you do this, you wind up
with this very bizarre four
times the real part of the
inner product of v and u,
divided by N0.
And you get it in exactly
the same way
that we got it before.
Namely you take this norm
here, which is an inner
product squared of v minus u.
Let me write it out.
I'll write it out here.
Norm squared of y minus a, is
the norm squared of y plus the
norm squared of a, plus the
inner product of minus ya,
plus the inner product
of minus ay.
What's the sum of these
two inner products?
This inner product, by
definition in terms of
integrals, is the integral
of minus y times a--
complex conjugate.
This is minus a times y--
So in one case the complex
conjugate is here.
In the other case it's
on the other term.
In other words this and
this are complex
conjugates of each other.
What happens when you add
two complex conjugates?
You get the real part
of the two of them.
Okay so when you add these two
things you just get that real
part there.
OK, and then when you
do the other term,
the same thing happens.
The same cancellation that
we had before occurs.
And these two inner products add
up so you wind up with the
real part of vu over N0
When we look at the picture
here, what does it mean?
Well I suggest you first
look at the one
dimensional case here.
Namely on this one dimensional
case think of V as being a one
dimensional complex
random variable.
Then we can draw a picture.
The picture make sense.
And what we're dealing with is
the real and imaginary parts,
and these distances here, when
you talk about the norm of V
minus a-- namely what
corresponds to this line here,
the length of this line--
what do you really mean by it?
If you took the inner product,
if you took the norm of v,
with i times a-- namely that
the square root of minus 1
times a-- would you get the same
thing or wouldn't you?
If I take a complex number, and
I take the inner product
of that complex number--
namely the product--
of that, when I take the inner
product of ya, is this the
same as the inner product
of y and i times a?
Not at all.
The two things are totally
different.
Namely, inner products
are complex things.
Norms are real things.
And these norms, when you're
dealing with complex numbers,
have real parts in them.
In other words, this distance
that we're talking about here
is not just the norm squared--
well it is the norm squared--
because the norm has this
complex feature built into it.
Because people kept making that
mistake all the time.
So they fudged the mathematics
to make it come out right.
But after doing that, you have
to fudge the mathematics to
come back to something that
makes sense here.
So you have the real part of
this inner product, here.
So in fact, what you're doing
when you're taking the inner
product of two vectors and
you're trying to relate it to
this plane here, this separation
plane, is you have
to look at that separation
plane.
You have to look at
that projection in
terms of real numbers.
Namely, you have to look
at the projection.
First as being a complex
projection of v onto a, which
gives you a complex number.
And then after you do that you
have to you visualize yourself
in a two dimensional
real space.
And you have to project once
more from the two dimensional
thing to the one dimensional
thing.
And here where we're just
looking at one dimension to
start with, we have to draw it
as a two dimensional space.
And suddenly we are dealing
with this real part there
while we're not dealing
with that here.
Which is why when people say
minimum distance detection
when they're dealing with
complex numbers it sounds
very, very simple.
But in fact, it's
not so simple.
If you view this in the complex
plane, is this a
linear operation or isn't it?
When you're looking at things
as complex vectors.
Is this thing a sub space of
the complex vector space?
No, it's not.
It's not a sub space.
Because, to be a sub space you
have to be able to multiply by
arbitrary scalors--
which includes complex
numbers-- and
stay in the same space.
And here the complex numbers
are important.
OK?
You should go back and
think about that.
You will be confused about it
for the first ten times you
think about it.
For those of you who stick with
it and carry through on
it, you'll be happy because
you'll never be
confused about it again.
OK, anyway thats real
numbers there.
And the most straightforward way
to deal with complex noise
is to first turn it
into real noise.
If you do that you never
get confused.
And otherwise you only have
half the analytical work.
You only have half the
writing to do.
But you never know whether
you've done the right thing
until you go back and check.
OK the probability of error
for maximum likelihood
detection, in other words where
the threshold for the
log likelihood ratio is zero, is
simply the same thing that
it was before.
Namely it's the q function.
This tale of the Gaussian
normal function.
Of the norm of a divided by the
square root of N0 over 2.
In other words it's the length
of a divided by the by the
length of a one standard
deviation of the noise.
When you put that in terms of,
well, if you write this as the
square root of the norm squared
then you get this
formula here.
Because e sub b is just
the energy of
these antipodal signals.
When you look at this in terms
of the complex random
variables, you get
the same thing.
OK?
You get u instead of a because,
in fact, in the
complex plane and the real
plane, distances turn out to
be the same.
But again, in all cases it's
square root of 2eb over n0
Now, that is true for any vector
at all where these
norms are appropriate.
When we start dealing with
functions what happens?
functions, what we're going to
do is we're going to take this
vector, we're going to turn it
into a wave form.
We're going to transmit
the wave form.
The wave form is going
to come back to us.
We're going to demodulate it,
get back to a number again.
And that's the next thing that
I want to talk about.
Because what I want to convince
you of is the
property of white Gaussian noise
which is so important.
Is that it doesn't make any
difference how you modulate.
All modulation systems
are the same.
All modulation schemes
All frequencies are the same.
There is no way you can avoid
white Gaussian noise.
There is no way you can
get screwed by it.
No matter what you do, the
same thing happens.
You can always take all these
problems where you're dealing
with wave forms.
You can convert them to finite
dimensional vector problems.
And when you convert it into
a finite dimensional vector
problem all of the orthonormal
functions that you're using
all pass away.
Because none of them are
relevant anymore.
OK?
That's the bottom line
of all of that.
OK.
We haven't really talked about
M-ARY hypothesis testing.
So I want to talk about
it a little bit now.
I talked about it just a
shade, but not much.
When we want to detect between
m different hypothesis--
namely in the vector case
we're going to now be
detecting not between antipodal
signals but m
signals which are placed
any place at all.
We already said what the MAP,
optimal MAP test was.
You see an observation, you're
trying to guess what the input
was, or what the
hypothesis was.
And in general, the MAP test
says try to find that j,
namely that hypothesis, for
which the a priori probability
of hypothesis j, times the
likelihood-- namely the
probability that you
see v given h of
v, given j is maximum.
OK, this is just standard
formula for finding a
posteriori probabilities.
Where you factor out the
marginal on, when you cancel
out the marginal on v.
In other words, what this rule
says is to do MAP testing,
what you do is you find the a
posteriori probabilities of
each of the hypotheses and you
choose the a posteriori
probability which is largest.
Perfect common sense.
The way we're going to do
that, the way which is
particularly convenient, is you
do it the same way that
we've been doing all along
for binary hypotheses.
The way to do a MAP test, at
least one way to do a MAP
test, is you compare every pair
of hypothesis and you
choose the most likely
of each pair.
And when you've got it all
done, you have a winner.
OK?
Mainly you can always compare
any objects if they're
comparable.
And after you compare each pair,
you take the one which
beats every other one and
that's the winner.
OK?
So what you do is you do a
pairwise test between each
hypothesis.
Namely, the likelihood ratio
of m relative to m prime.
Is the likelihood of the output
conditional on m,
divided by the likelihood
of the output
conditional on m prime.
You compare it with the a priori
probabilities, and the
point here is that nothing
really has been added.
You have the same problem
you had before, OK?
Nothing new.
It's just gotten n square
times as complicated.
The computation is free now, so
you have exactly the same
problem that you had before.
If you have to write it out on
paper, yeah it's much more
complicated.
But conceptually, it's not.
You have to remember that
the signals are
not antipodal here.
But what we're dealing with
mostly at this point is this
Gaussian noise case.
And here, what you observe,
is signal plus noise.
And Z is zero-mean jointly Gauss
and s is discrete with n
possible values.
OK, so let's see what
that means.
Here's a picture of it.
If you have three singles which
are each two dimensional
vectors, suppose one of them is
s0, suppose one of them is
s1, suppose one of them s2.
OK?
And now you want to pairwise,
see which one is most likely.
And let's think of doing this
first for the maximum
likelihood case.
What do you do?
You set up a perpendicular
bisector between s0 and s1.
That's this line here.
And if you weren't to worry
about s2, everything on this
side would go into
H equals zero.
And everything on this side
would go into H equals one.
Namely, whatever's closest
to this point
gets mapped into it.
Whatever's closest to this point
If you're doing MAP testing,
what happens?
In the test between this and
this you had the same
orientation for this line, but
it just gets shifted a little
bit this way or a little
bit this way.
OK?
Then you compare this
with this and you
get this line here.
Same argument as before.
It's just comparing two things
are not antipodal they've just
been shifted off from the
origin a little bit.
But for the maximum likelihood
you still take the
perpendicular bisector
between them.
And then you compare these two
and you got a perpendicular
bisector between those.
And these perpendicular
bisectors, in two dimensions,
always come together
at one point.
And I don't know why.
And if you looked at it often
enough, you probably know why.
And you could probably prove
it in about ten minutes.
But in fact these things always
come together somehow.
If you do the MAP test, they
always come together also.
You can shift each of them in
arbitrary ways and somehow
they always come together
in this point.
OK, the separators between
decision regions here are the
set of points where the real
part of the inner product, vu,
is constant.
OK?
Again, for dealing with complex
vectors, you got to
both do the projection and then
do the projection again
onto the real part of
this projection.
So it's sort of a two
way projection.
Because probability densities in
j dimensional complex space
are really 2j dimensional
quantities.
And when you're comparing
them, you really have to
compare things in terms
of that 2j dimensional
probability density.
OK so that's why
that comes out.
These are best visualized in
separate, real, and imaginary
coordinates.
And for maximum likelihood
detection, the regions are
Voronoi regions.
OK?
We talked about Voronoi regions
in terms of doing
quantization.
And we found out if you wanted
to minimize the mean square
error, what you did was you
set up regions, which are
perpendicular bisectors between
all the points.
And here you get the same
perpendicular bisectors
between the points.
And everybody-- because
of that-- thinks that
quantization has a great deal
to do with error probability
when you have large
sets of signals.
And it probably has something
to do with it, but I don't
know what other than the fact
that you've got Voronoi
regions in each case.
Which is what you get.
OK, so that's where we are with
both complex vectors and
real vectors.
I want to now just restrict
attention to real wave forms
so I don't have to keep going
back and forth between the
real and imaginary case.
If you're thinking in terms of
QAM, we're now thinking in
terms of what goes
on at passband.
Why do we want to think of
what goes on at passband?
Because that's where
the noise hits us.
And in a fundamental sense,
all of the stuff about QAM
really isn't fundamental.
I mean, it's all done-- all this
stuff down at passband--
is all done because people
thought it was easier to
implement things there.
It's the only reason for all of
that mess with dealing with
all of these complex signals.
If we really want to deal with
the problem in a fundamental
way, what we want to
do is to choose a
signal set up at passband.
Do detection up at passband.
And then after we find out what
the optimal detection is
up at passband, see if we can
actually implement that down
at baseband.
So the fundamental problem is
looking at single sets up at
passband and analyze
what they all mean.
OK, so we're going to generalize
both PAM and QAM.
And now we're going to look at
the general problem where what
we're dealing with
is a single set.
Which is m signals.
Each of them we're going to
visualize as a vector in j
dimensional space. m different
signals, j dimensional space.
Don't confuse the dimension
of space with
the number of signals.
OK?
You can have an arbitrarily
large dimensional space and
just binary signals.
Or you can have an arbitrarily
large set of signals and you
can be dealing with it.
In PAM, for example, it's just
all done in one dimension.
So j there is equal to 1.
QAM j is equal to 2.
We now want to look at
more general things.
Partly because we want to look
at orthoginal wave forms.
We want to look at orthoginal
wave forms for two reasons.
One is that we would like to
show that by using orthoginal
wave forms, you can reach what
we've called the capacity of a
white Gaussian noise channel.
And two, when we get to studying
wireless it's very,
very useful to base
signal sets on
orthonormal sets of functions.
And we'll see why each
of those things
happen as we move on.
OK so we're going to denote the
single set as the set of
vectors, a1 up to a sub m.
And in that signal set, we will
denote the vector, a sub
m, as a j dimensional vector,
a sub m1, a sub m2, up to a
sub m capital j.
So j is at the dimension.
m is just a component
of these vectors.
I'm going to create
a set of capital J
orthonormal wave forms.
They can be anything at all.
I don't care what they are.
I'm going to use those
orthonormal wave forms in
order to modulate the signal--
which is now a vector--
up to some waveform.
This is really the standard way
we've been turning signals
into waveforms all along.
It's just that now we're looking
at the general case
instead of all of these specific
cases that we've been
looking at.
All of the special cases all fit
into this same category.
So we have these capital
M different waveforms.
And we're going to transmit one
of them and then at the
receiver we're going to try to
decide which one was sent.
OK, well one of the reasons why
I'm going through all of
this generality is that there's
an issue we haven't
talked about yet.
All of the stuff we've done on
detection so far we have had
one hypothesis.
Could be M-ary could
be binary.
We have sent something.
We have received something.
We have made a detection.
OK?
In other words, for all of the
antipodal stuff we've done, we
built a communication system.
We set it all up.
We transmitted one bit.
We've received the one bit.
We've made a decision on it.
Then we've torn down the
communication system
and we've gone home.
You really want to transmit a
whole sequence of symbols or
signals or waveforms.
So we want to deal
with that now.
So we need some way
to transmit a
succession of M-ary signals.
And we'll call this succession
of signals-- mainly the
signals are the things that
get chosen from the signal
set-- we'll call them
x of k, k of z.
Which is what we've been
calling them all along.
We've been transmitting a
sequence of things when we're
dealing with PAM.
And aa in am.
Why do I call them
xk instead of ak?
Well I can't call them ak
because when I talk about ak
I'm talking about the k'th
signal in the signal set.
And here what I'm talking about
now is transmitting a
sequence of choices.
Each one of these choices, the
first choice is a choice from
this set here.
The second thing that I send
is a choice from this set.
The third thing that I send
So x1, x2, x3, and x4 and so
forth are different choices
among these M-ary signals.
If m is 2 to the 6--
OK in other words, every time
I transmit a signal I'm
transmitting six bits.
OK.
In a communication system
we transmit six bits.
Then we transmit another
six bits.
Then we transmit another six
bits, and so on forever.
OK, so I need to talk about
these things as ways of a
succession of signals.
The thing that I'm trying to
get at is, how do you know
when you send one of these
signals that you don't have to
worry about the other signals?
How do you know that they don't
interfere with each other?
Well, we sort of solved the
problem of them interfering
with each other in dealing with
Nyquist, but we haven't
dealt with that problem at all
since we started to talk about
random processes.
So we don't know whether we've
really solved it or not.
So at this point we have to
solve that problem, and that's
what we're aiming at.
So, the one way to be able to
transmit a whole sequence of
signals is to have these choices
of vectors here and to
develop a set of orthonormal
waveforms, v1 up to v sub j,
which all have the property that
if you time shift them
each by capital T,
they're stilll--
if you time shift them by
capital T, they have to be
orthonormal to each other.
The question you're facing is
whether these things that
you're transmitting are
orthoganol to all of these
things that you're
transmitting.
Now, in the Nyquist problem, we
dealt with the problem of
how do you take one waveform
here and make it orthonormal
to all of its time shifts.
And we solved that problem.
In the quiz you solved the
problem-- although you
probably didn't recognize it--
of dealing with orthonormal
functions both
in time and in frequency.
And that's the kind of thing
we would like to use here.
If I take a set of orthonormal
pulses and then I modulate
those orthonormal pulses up
to a higher frequency--
which is out of the range of
this first frequency-- then I
can send one sequence of
orthonormal functions down
here, another set of orthonormal
functions up here
in a different frequency
range.
Another one up here in
a different frequency
range and so forth.
So then all of these orthonormal
functions are
going to be orthonormal
to each other.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you saying
that each x of
k is its own frequency?
Because each x of k is
infinitely long.
PROFESSOR: Each x of
k is going to--
each x of k is just a vector
of j components.
I'm going to modulate that
vector, x of k, into a
waveform, x of t, which might be
finite duration or it might
be infinite duration.
I mean, it's going to go to zero
very, very fast, anyway.
And whether it is absolutely
time limited or not is
something I don't really care
about at this point.
But the point is I can create
functions where, in fact, I
have a whole sequence of
functions here and they're
orthonormal to all
of the shifts.
One way of doing this, for
example, is to make capital J
a bunch of little time
shifts on functions.
I can pick a function p of t,
which is orthonormal to all of
its shifts, in terms of t1.
I can send J of those pulses
to take care of x of k.
And then I can use a capital T
in here, which is j times this
little t that I was using.
And I can send another
set of functions.
So I can do that, I can move
up and down in frequency.
I can choose any old
set of orthonormal
functions that I want to.
But the thing that I want to do
is I want to make sure that
for each vector, x of k, that
I'm sending in time when I
modulate it to a waveform, that
waveform is orthonormal
to the waveforms for
every other k.
And there are lots of
ways of doing that.
OK, mainly there are
lots of choices
of orthonormal functions.
OK so anyway what I'm going to
be doing is making all of
these signals orthogonal
to each other.
OK, so the transmitting waveform
for this sequence of
modulated signals is x of t,
which is the sum of x of k
times t minus kt.
Mainly the same thing we
were doing before.
Except now I have also the
problem that each of these
waveforms, x of k of t,
has to be some sum
of orthonormal functions.
So the problem becomes a little
more difficult than
what it was before.
But in fact it's--
I mean this is just standard
communication.
Every wireless system
in the world uses
this kind of scheme.
They don't use QAM or PAM.
They use something much
more like this.
OK, so now our problem is you
want to detect a generic x
from this sequence.
OK, in other words, one of these
x sub k in sequence, we
want to be able to detect
what signal was sent.
We want to detect which
hypothesis chose a signal
which was then formed into
a waveform, x of k of t.
And if I can do this
for one k, I can do
it for all of them.
So I want to solve the problem
for one generic value of k.
OK, how is this problem
different from what I was
looking at before?
Before I was looking at the
problem where we built a
communication system, we tuned
it all up, we sent one bit.
We detected it, we tore it all
down and we went home.
Now what we're doing is
we're building the
communication system.
We're tuning at all up.
We're sending a sequence
of bits.
And then all I'm interested in
at the moment is detecting the
k'th of them.
But if I find a way to detect
the k'th of them, I can then
use it for every k.
OK?
So I'm going to build a detector
which is going to
detect, in some optimal
way, each one of these
signals that gets sent.
OK?
Is it clear how the problem
is different?
Mainly I have to deal with the
fact that these other signals
are floating around there.
And that's my problem.
Ok, so the input to the channel
is hypothesis H. That
takes values one up the m.
The symbol, m, is mapped into
the signal, vector a sub m,
it's modulated into x of t
equals summation over j, a sub
mj, phi j of t.
OK, this waveform, now, is a
function of which particular
signal I'm sending.
Which is a function of which
particular hypothesis entered
the encoder.
The trouble with this material
is all the complication comes
in this awful notation,
which you can't avoid.
Because you're dealing with
sequences, you're dealing with
vectors, and you're dealing
with wave forms
all at the same time.
What's going on, after you
understand it, you'll say why
was it so difficult to
understand this?
Because eventually when you see
it, it becomes very, very
simple And I understand why
there's just too much stuff
all going on at the same time.
OK, so what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to take these
J, capital J, orthonormal
waveforms.
And we've already seen that you
can start out with any old
orthonormal waveforms and if
you want to you can extend
that set of waveforms into
an orthonormal set that
spans all of L2.
OK?
So I'm going to imagine
that we've done that.
It's taken us a long time,
but we've done it.
We're all through with it.
We have this orthonormal
set now.
If I'm smart, that orthonormal
set, which I generated, will
also include easy ways to
represent each of the other
signals that we're
going to send.
But I don't care about
that right now.
All I'm dealing with is this one
hypothesis that came in.
This one signal, a sub m--
oh, the hypothesis m, the
signal a sub m, an the
particular time instant, k, and
this waveform that gets
sent, which can be represented
as the first J terms in this
orthonormal sequence.
OK, so what I'm going
to get then is the
received random process.
Is going to be a sum --
and forgot about the
j prime now--
I can represent it as a sum of
coefficients times these
orthonormal waveforms.
OK, that's what we've done for
arbitrary sequences, and then
we've said we can also do it
for at least well defined
random processes.
I'm going to make, I mean,
instead of making this an
infinite dimensional sum, I
want to make it a finite
dimensional sum where J prime
is very, very large.
Say, 10 to the fiftieth
if you want to.
I don't want to make it
infinite, I want to look at
what happens when I let it
get bigger or smaller.
So I'm expanding Y of t over
an orthonormal expansion.
But I'm not going all the way.
I'm just going to try to do
maximum likelihood detection
with this finite set
of observations.
So I wont do quite as well
as if I have all the
observations, but I'll
still do pretty well.
We hope.
OK, well so Y sub j--
the output that I see in
this degree of freedom
corresponding to
phi sub j of t.
Is going to be xj-- what I
sent in that degree of
freedom-- plus zj.
And there are j degrees of--
capital J degrees of freedom
that I'm using.
So the outputs in those degrees
of freedom, namely in
the phi1 of t, phi2 of t, phi3
of t directions in this L2
space are going to be the
signal plus the noise.
For all of these dimensions.
And Yj is just going to
be equal to zj for
all the other terms.
OK, now I want to add one
extra thing here.
What I should be putting in here
is all the other signals
that are going to
be transmitted.
I don't know how to do that.
Notationally it gets
very confusing.
So what I'm going to say is,
OK Z sub j here is not just
Gaussian noise.
Z sub j is Gaussian noise plus
all the signals from other
time instance that
we're sending.
Plus all of the signals that
anybody else is sending.
If we're dealing with wireless
then we have
interference from them.
Plus any old other thing you
can think of. z sub j is
everything but in these other
degrees of freedom.
In these other coordinates.
This solves another problem
for us, because when we
defined white Gaussian noise
we had this problem.
That we could only say it looked
white over the region
of interest.
We could only say it looked
white over some time span.
Because the earth keeps
changing, you know.
And over some frequency span
because different frequencies
behave in different ways.
So this also allows us to have
different Gaussian random
variables here.
So when we have arbitrary random
variables here, they
can be Gaussian or
non-Gaussian.
They don't have to have
the same variance.
They don't have to
have anything.
What I am going to assume is
that these out of band, out of
sense, out of view random
variables are all independent
of the things that
I am looking at.
And for white Gaussian
noise, that's true.
All of these random variables
here are independent of all of
these random variables here.
For these first capital J
different random variables
that I'm interested in.
And all these random variables
are independent of they input
that I'm using.
OK?
In other words, a hypothesis
came into the transmitter that
generated a signal.
The signal got turned into a
waveform, which is defined
solely in terms of these J
degrees of freedom, these J
orthonormal functions.
And now everything everywhere
else is independent of these J
functions that I'm
interested in.
Why is that a shaky
assumption?
Anybody think of a
situation where
that is absolute nonsense?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The stuff from the
other message had t--
PROFESSOR: Mm hmm.
AUDIENCE: You said t of j is
not just Gaussian noise--
PROFESSOR: It also includes all
those other signals, yes.
Well, but I want to assume that
those other signals are
independent of this particular
signal that I'm sending.
But in fact that is making
a pretty big assumption.
Because one of the things that a
lot of people like to do is,
when these bits come into a
channel, the first thing they
do is they encode the bits
for error correction.
And then they take those bits
that come out of the error
correction device, error
encoding device, which are as
correlated as could be.
And they're all statistically
very dependent, because we
want to use that statistical
dependence
later to correct errors.
And this assumption that I'm
making here says, "no that's
not the case.
I'm assuming that all that other
stuff is independent of
what I'm transmitting here."
So I'm very specifically
assuming at this point that all
of that stuff has not been
encoded first.
That I'm sending something
which is independent of
everything else.
Which is going to enter
this channel.
We'll just assume that and after
we get done assuming it
and seeing what the consequence
of it is, we'll go
back and see what
it all means.
OK, so for a little
more notation.
I'm going to call the
vector, Y, the first
J, capital J, outputs.
I'm going to call the vector Y
prime all the other outputs.
Now intuitively what were aiming
at is, we would like to
say this stuff doesn't have
anything to do with it.
We're going to base our
decision on this.
But I want to prove that to you,
and show you why it works
and why it doesn't.
And the noise I'm going to
break up the same way.
Z is this the first J components
of the noise.
And Z prime is the other
components of noise.
So what I have is that the
output, the output that I want
to look at, namely the
output this vector
of dimension J output.
Which is equal to a vector of
dimension J input plus of a
vector of dimension J
noise is equal to--
well Y is equal X plus Z. And
the out of band stuff, the
output, is just these noise
and other signals.
OK?
And I want to assume that
Z prime, X, and Z are
statistically independent.
Question, test your
probability.
If I assume that Z prime is
independent of Z, and if I
assume that Z prime is
independent of X, does that
mean that Z prime is independant
of X and Z?
If a is independent of b, and
a is independent of c, is a
necessarily independent
of the pair bc?
How many think that's true?
Better go back and
study a little
elementary probability again.
And the notes are occasionally
wrong about that, too.
So you shouldn't feel, you
shouldn't feel badly about it.
No, the problem is you really
need this joint independence
between all three of them.
I could, for example, make X
plus Y be equal to Z. I could
do this with discrete
random variables.
Which are equally probably
zero and one.
And make the plus equal
to a mod 2 operation.
And if I did that, each pair
would be independent of each
other, and the triple would be
very, very highly dependant.
So anyway, I want to assume
that Z prime, X, and Z are
statistically independent.
In other words, what I'm doing
is saying, "If I assume that,
what's the consequence of it?"
OK, so the likelihood then, the
probability density of the
output, Y-- this is the output
in the first j dimensions
given a particular hypothesis
Y-- is equal to the
probability density of the noise
evaluated at Y minus am.
Where this is the signal that
goes with this hypothesis,
well with am.
Times the probability density
of Y prime for Z prime.
OK?
And I don't even have to assume
that this is Gaussian.
All I've done is to assume that
these random variables
are independent of these
random variables.
And therefore this probability
density is multiplied by this
probability density.
OK, well that's kind of neat.
Because if I put a different i
in here in place of m, I get
this thing.
Changes all around.
F sub Z of Y minus a sub i.
But this stuff, which
is out of band,
doesn't change at all.
When I form the likelihood
ratio, what I get then is this
divided by that.
What has happened to Y prime?
Y prime has disappeared.
In other words, Y1 to Y sub j
are a sufficient statistic for
this problem.
We've shown that sufficient
statistics are the only thing
you need to use to do maximum
likelihood detection.
OK?
In other words, all those other
signals, all that other
noise, all that stuff from out
of band has disappeared.
Now let's go back to the fact
that we were looking at a
finite dimensional problem.
What happens now when I
make j prime bigger?
When I start enlarging
j prime?
What happens to all these
probabilities that we're
talking about?
This probability density goes
ape because of this term here.
We're talking about a
probability density here which
is involving more and
more and more terms.
I can't talk about that.
It doesn't go to any limit.
It goes to absolute nonsense
as j prime gets big.
But if I form the likelihood
ratio before I go to the
limit, then I can go to the
limit quite easily.
Because there isn't any
limit involved there.
OK, in other words this is the
likelihood ratio between
hypothesis m and hypothesis i,
if in fact I looked at this
entire infinite amount
of observation.
This is all I need to make
the optimal MAP decision.
OK, so there's a theorem here
which is called the theorem of
irrelevance.
This is something that
Wosencraft and Jacobs in their
book on communication many years
ago stressed a lot in
trying to come up with a single
space viewpoint of
communication.
And you'll see why this really
does give you a single point
viewpoint of communication.
It says that assume that Z
prime is statistically
independent of the pair X and Z.
Then the MAP detection of X
from the observation of Y and Y
prime depends only on Y. The
observed sample value of
Y prime is irrelevant.
OK?
So you can do all of detection
theory, you can do all of
communication, simply forgetting
about that
irrelevant stuff.
Because of the theorem we can
stick to finite dimensional
vectors and the other signals
can be viewed
as part of Z prime.
So you don't have to
worry about them.
So long as each signal is
independent of each other--
which means that these groups of
bits, the first group a bit
is used to form a sub x sub 1.
The next group, the form x sub
2, the next group the form x
sub 3, and so forth.
So long as those sequences of
bits are independent of each
other, you're fine.
Now, suppose they aren't?
What happens then?
Interesting question.
We said that if they are
independent, I can really do
maximum likelihood detection
on the whole sequence.
If they aren't independent,
suppose I say, "oh I don't
care about that." I'm just going
to use this portion of
the output to make my decision
and not worry about whether
this is independent
of anything else.
I can do that, this still is
going to give me the optimal
maximum likelihood detection in
terms of the observation y1
up to y sub j.
So in other words, whether I
have coding done before this
or not doesn't make
any difference.
I can still use maximum
likelihood detection on the
basis of y1 up to y sub j.
What the theorem says is if
the out of band stuff--
both these inputs and the
noise-- are independent of
what I'm trying to detect,
maximum likelihood becomes the
optimum thing to do for
equally likely inputs.
And otherwise, it's a perfectly
reasonable thing to
do but it's not optimal.
Now, a lot of people--
and we'll see some
examples of this
when we look at wireless--
in fact, use coding.
Then they use this particular
kind of detection where they
forget about all of the added
information from other signals.
They make a decision on each of
these x sub k, namely each
of the M-ary signals that
goes in, they make a
hard decision on it.
It's called a hard decision, not
because it's difficult it
because they refuse to ever
go back and change it.
If they just say likelihoods and
try to put things together
in the final decoder, it's
called soft decoding.
Otherwise it's called
hard decoding.
If you do soft decoding,
it has to work better.
Because you're making, in a
sense, a better decision
because eventually you're
using more information.
So soft decisions are better
than hard decisions.
Used to be that everybody used
hard decisions because hard
decisions were easy and soft
decisions were hard.
Strange, strange thing.
But anyway that's changed.
Why?
Well it ought to
be obvious why.
Because anything you build now
cost a tenth of what it used
to cost to build it.
I heard Irwin Jacobs awhile
ago saying that one of the
things that they always did when
they were designing new
pieces of equipment is they
would look at how much it
would cost to build
these devices.
And then, as opposed to most
companies which would say
that's too expensive let's find
the cheaper way to do it,
they said OK how long is it
going to take for us to do it,
and what is the price of
components going to be by time
we got it done?
And they would usually say, well
it's going to cost a year
before we can go into
mass production.
By that time, everything will
cost less than a half of what
it's costing now.
So let's go ahead and
do it the right way.
So again the argument comes
that you can do
the hard thing now.
Which is soft decisions, and
that's what most people do at
this point.
Let me give you one more picture
to get ready for what
we're doing next time.
Because it's a nice picture
of different signal sets.
Because we've just talked
abstractly of having multiple
signals viewed as vectors, and
this will give us some idea of
what all of these mean.
I can have two signals, a binary
signal set, and I can
insist on the signals being
orthogonal to each other.
Which is a nice thing
to do some times.
But then I can look at it and
I can say, "how can I make
that a better signal system?"
The trouble with this signal
system is it's not antipodal.
It's not antipodal because
somehow by alternating between
these two orthogonal signals--
there's a mean between them--
and I'm transmitting that mean
plus the difference.
And the difference between them
is minus 0.7 and plus 0.7
in that direction that way.
If you can, I guess you
can't see it that way.
In this direction this way.
Well anyway, OK.
A better thing to do than this
is this, which is called bi
orthogonal.
So you take orthogonal signals
and then you have a signal set
consisting of four signals and
two dimensional space.
We then talk about orthogonal
signals and
higher dimensional space.
You can talk about three
orthogonal signals in three
dimensional space here.
There, there, and there.
So that's m equals
3 and j equals 3.
If you do the same thing
that we did here--
we're going to make this into
an equilateral triangle.
Namely we're going to center
it around the center.
If we do the same thing that
we did here we're going to
turn this into a set of six
waveforms which are still
using the three degrees of
freedom, but at least get us
more signals.
For the same number of
degrees of freedom.
So you can extend this picture
as far as you want to.
You can talk about many, many
orthogonal signals going into
many more degrees of freedom.
For each one of them you
can come up with a
simplex set of signals.
The nice thing about the simplex
set of signals is that
all of the signals are arranged
around the center point.
They're all equally distant
from each other.
You can get these for every
dimension by starting with
these and simply taking the mean
out, which loses you one
dimension and makes this
sort of ideal set.
Well tomorrow-- on Wednesday
what we're going to do is,
we're going to talk about these
large sets here, and see
what happens.
And we'll see that you in
fact get to channel
capacity this way.
OK.